yeah we all want low crime but what are
the other ways that we can get in it
rather than the expensive route of
incarceration hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
furryz in TV and today we're talking
with Professor Michael stole he teaches
public policy at UCLA in his author of
the recent book why are so many
Americans in prison Michael thanks for
being here thank you for having me
incarceration rates have skyrocketed
since the mid 1970s but violent crime
was at an all-time low so can you
explain the disconnect here and why you
think the costs of mass incarceration
significantly outweigh the benefits 3040
years ago we incarcerate the United
States about a hundred people per
hundred thousand but the United States
ramped up that incarceration fivefold so
that we are straight now 500 people per
100,000 so every every 1011 people that
you meet you know someone's either gonna
know someone's in prison has been in
prison with a record or you met them and
they just run they're going off to
prison that increase that we saw 80% of
that through our analysis was driven by
policy changes not by the increased
criminality of citizens in the United
States in fact crime rates as you said
has fallen so all of the increase is
driven by mostly increases in sentencing
particularly for violent crime this is
at the state level and at the federal
level most of it is driven by changes in
drug policy definitions of offending as
well as high incarceration rates for
those that have been found guilty of
certain kinds of drug possessions in
layman's terms I mean do we have that
many dangerous criminals on the street
to explain these high incarceration
rates so when you incarcerate and you
target your enforcement efficiently you
get the most criminally prone first
after that you start incarcerating what
we call the marginal offenders those are
offenders who are less likely to commit
crime repeatedly and so the bang for the
buck that we get in society from
incarceration those individuals Falls
dramatically I saw an article that in
New York City is paying one hundred and
sixty eight thousand dollars per inmate
so can you talk about what's driving
these financial costs a little bit more
who what what's responsible
right well I mean it's all the
production of of prisons right so it's
not only the brick-and-mortar costs of
the facility which actually that cost
Falls over time because it's a fixed
cost once you build a prison so it's the
bricks and mortar it is the personnel to
man the prisons right so that would be
security guards and in California that's
very expensive because the prison is
fairly strong prison guard units fairly
strong and wages and benefits are fairly
high and so those are enormous costs and
then those costs vary across states
California is a high-cost state land is
expensive so it's going to be higher
than say in Alabama Mississippi
California also has really terrible
conditions I mean they're pouring so
much money into these systems but
they've been just the conditions have
been described as unconstitutional
because they're so cruel and unusual
they have been defined by the federal
system as being unconstitutional the
number of people per per State
Penitentiary is way beyond the capacity
almost by 20-25 percent right and so one
way that the state has been able to
maintain or reduce their cause per
person is to drive up overcrowding so
the more people that you can get out of
prison you know you've been able to
manage the cost but that comes at
tremendous I think consequence and you
have a different set of prescriptions
for prison alternatives how can you talk
about those a little bit one of the
things that I think needs to be done and
we know this is politically difficult is
that there has to be reform in
sentencing and the problem with reform
and sentencing is that the political
dynamics of sentence reform are
asymmetrical that is it's it's easier to
get tough on crime than it is to be
perceived as getting soft on crimes but
there was a window of opportunity when
states started to feel the budget crisis
as a result of the Great Recession and
tax revenues fell dramatically states
were under pressure to figure out cost
savings and you know state prisons are
eating up an increasing share of general
revenue and so that was a window of
opportunity for states to rethink their
sentencing and even in California we
rethought sentencing so we've relaxed
the stringency on three strikes and
other get tough on crime states like
Texas have actually done some sentencing
reform and so as Florida so we think
that has to be on the table
no matter how politically difficult the
conversation has to be made in terms of
the costs and benefits like yeah we all
want low crime but what are the other
ways that we can get at it rather than
the expensive route of incarceration the
other big idea I think from the book is
that most of the convictions and
sentencing take place in smaller
political jurisdictional levels than
states so our idea is that counties
should have skin in the game where at
some level they're contributing towards
the cost of incarceration so that
counties could be more efficient or more
intelligent about whom they send to
prison and if it was the case that they
had to pay for part of the tab of prison
rather than just the states we think
that they would be much more likely to
be judicious and who they send to prison
what other interesting politicians have
to cater to that makes her forming
prison so hard the other concerns have
to do with the stakeholders and the
prison industry I mean people who work
in prisons who build prisons all have an
interest in having prisons they play a
formidable role in reforming either
sentencing reform or prison reform do
you think public perception is shifting
at all in terms of how the public is
viewing drug offenders I do think
there's a growing plurality of people
who would probably agree that there's a
there's a role for prison but that at
some point the bang for the buck
diminishes quickly and that there's
other things that we could do with
public money to get these same crime
reducing effects there's one camp that I
think thinks and that kind of lends
there's another camp that I think sees
it through some notion of justice so I
think the ballot initiative approval to
be lenient on three strikes was a notion
of justice so that someone who's caught
for stealing a bag of chips being sent
to prison for the rest of his or her
life just seemed utterly ridiculous and
I think a justice argument was probably
more in play there then but I think the
more a fiscal conservative view which is
that you know this isn't money not well
spent we can do something else to get
the same goal
great well thanks Michael for being here
thank you for buddy reason TV I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer